need motivation what everybody nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was designed to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself so get ready for some Purpose
Driven wisdom from Bob Proctor to give
you the motivation confidence and belief
that you need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one discover your purpose I don't think
you determine what your purpose is I
think you discover what your purpose is
there's a difference
determining indicates deciding and I
don't think you decide I think if you go
about it the right way you discover it
like there's some people that should be
painting all day
they're great artists I think
Michelangelo was obviously a great
artist it's great sculptor I mean that
was his purpose in his life well I
believe my purpose is doing what I'm
doing your purpose is why you get out of
bed in the morning do you know why you
get up well most people say well it's
their go to work well that'd be a good
reason to stay in bed you know you say
well everybody's doing it that'll be
another reason to stay in bed if you're
ever doing what everybody's doing you're
probably going in the wrong direction
your purpose is your reason for living
what you want to do is sit down and
maybe take a pen and a pad and then ask
yourself what do I really love doing now
you may have to spend a while at this
you might get up an hour early every
morning and go sit under a tree
somewhere if you're in a nice climate or
pick a favorite chair someplace where
you're not going to be disturbed and
totally relaxed and say if I could spend
my life doing something what do I really
love doing now since you don't ask
yourself that question every day it
might take
well for this answer to come to the
surface but it comes to your
consciousness and it may take a while
you may have to do this every morning
for three months but it would be well
invested the time rule number two don't
waste your minutes how many times have
you had somebody say to you hey have you
got a minute Bob we got a minute in one
minute I want you to think about that I
read a poem one time I said I have only
just a minute only 60 seconds and it was
forced upon me I can't refuse that I
didn't seek it and I didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it I must
suffer if I lose it give a count if I
abuse it it's only a tiny little minute
but eternity is in it well any rate I
thought I'm gonna put this on the video
I'm just gonna share with everybody just
this one little part out of the seminar
I'm making I want you to look at this
Sam timer and let this I want you to
think about your life the sand in the
top of the glass represents the future
the sand and the bottom of the glass
represents the past now Genoa we know
what's in the past and young we can't do
anything about it do you know what the
trick is
you don't know how much sands and the
top of the glass you may think you have
a lot you might only have a little then
again you may think you have a little
and you might have a lot when I was a
little boy I was raised by my
grandmother and I don't know when I was
little
after she was probably 60 but as long as
I can remember
redwoods saying I'll soon begun there
I'll soon be gone well you know we loved
her she was really an angel of God but
we thought she was never gonna go she
lived to be 94 for 30-some years I'll
soon be gone she didn't think she had
much time left she had 34 years left now
about the same time I had a buddy of
mine Bob Yates he was just 16 and bang
he run into the abutment of a bridge and
his life was snuffed out if you had
asked him a half hour before how much
sand he had left he would have said at
least a half a century he didn't have a
half an hour see the trick is we don't
know how much sand we have left
the future we don't know the past it's
gone now the only thing you can deal
with is what's right here right now and
if you look the sand is always moving
now think of this you see I was working
on that and then I was working on a
graph I've got here at my computer and
I'm thinking that the time somebody said
- have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute do
you know if you're running fifty
thousand dollars a year a minutes 42
cents a half-hour is $12.50 if we take
that ahead of it if you're earning
$80,000 a year a minute 67 cents half
hours $20 yearning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute and
then it cost you a dollar 25 a minute
and a half hours thirty seven dollars
and fifty cents so do you see if
somebody said you want to stop for a cup
of coffee
well if you're earning a quarter of a
million dollars a year a minute is two
dollars and eight cents half hours
$62.50 and then of course you've got the
coffee to pay for on top of that so do
you see the point is this this is all
we've got right here right now
we don't know how much we have left in
the future but we do know what we've got
now and I have found the people that win
are the people who make up their mind
then I'm gonna waste the minutes they're
gonna be productive they're gonna make
it happen
every minute rule number three stand out
the success was the progressive
realisation of a worthy ideal anyone
that has a goal and they're moving
towards it they're successful
most people think that you're successful
if you have a lot of money quite often
you have a lot of money if you're
successful but it isn't I wouldn't say
mother Teresa has a lot of money okay
but she's a pretty successful lady so
it's you so that barrier tizzies well
there's there's a couple of them okay I
think there's two barriers one is our
conditioning the conditioning that takes
place in our subconscious mind from the
time were infants all we can do is act
like the people around this that's why
we learn their language we learned that
there was ten languages spoken in our
home we learned ten languages without
any trouble there's usually one and
that's the only one we ever learn and we
grow older and we think I couldn't learn
another language we're looking a hundred
if we wanted to you can do anything but
I think we're conditioned we have a real
strong conditioning usually with not
some very good ideas and then that
that's the the barrier that's inside is
the one that's outside of us is our
environment we have a tendency to act
like everybody around us and if you
think about this it doesn't make a lot
of sense
because if you study statistics 95
percent of the people live their entire
life and never lived the way they want
to live you know that 95 percent of the
population in this country let's say in
North America okay
the richest continent in the history of
the world they all work productively
let's say for 40 of their 65 years okay
and they'll end up with her to be any
money there's gotta be something wrong
so just my 5% of the people end up
financially comfortable or independent
are you trying to depress this bump
that's no actually I think it's I think
it's quite an exciting idea because you
see the idea behind it is that anybody
can win anyone at all
but if we start studying these
statistics I think we'll arrive at the
conclusion Jesus better start thinking
for myself rather than follow everybody
most people they get a job they look
around to see how everybody else is
doing their work and they start doing it
the same way they should stop and think
I wonder if any of these people know
what they're doing is there a better way
to do it but don't we have a need to fit
in I mean we don't want it we don't want
to stand out we don't to get fired we
don't make waves
exactly exactly just fall into line you
know take a number be like everybody
around now that'd be great in the animal
kingdom but human beings aren't supposed
to live that way I think we should make
a few waves we should maybe stand out be
different not not for the sake of being
different okay but because we are
different we all think different
thoughts and I believe we should start
to think and build images in our mind of
what we'd like to do and then set out
and do it okay that Merson did that
edison did that Marconi did that
Samuel Morse did that Buckminster Fuller
did that we could go on and on and on
okay we're different they stood out they
made a few waves rule number four seek
failures you should seek failures see if
you're playing it safe you're not gonna
win if you're playing it safe like that
all say you know you were topping your
little girl better to be safe than sorry
well that's a bunch of crap
it's not better be safe than sorry it's
by trying things that you figure out how
far you can go you've got to get outside
the box like it's reported Edison tried
three thousand ways before he built the
incandescent light he said he didn't
deal three thousand times he said there
was three thousand different steps to
building a light bulb well there's
different steps to get to where you're
going and I really do treat winning and
losing exactly the same I do not let it
upset me do you think that's a big part
of why you're so successful well it's
part of why I enjoy it yeah I think it
is because I'll try anything like if if
I'm into an idea the idea of losing
never enters my mind see I have worked
with giants I had the good fortune of
working with Sir Edmund Hillary he was
the first man to stand on top of the
world and I worked with him on three
different occasions and the only
difference in that Hillary and Bob
Proctor is in his his size
now he's gone now but he was a big man
when he shook hands with me his hand
wrapped right around mine I felt like Oh
dwarf you know and and talked into him
like it never entered his mind he
wouldn't get to the top of the mountain
but he failed in 1951 he failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the month know people had died
for centuries trying to do that he said
I knew if I could see it in here I could
hold it out here still a man wrote that
in the book you can see it in your head
can hold it your hand and that's right
and if you're not prepared to lose
you're never gonna win because you're
always playing it safe and there's no
there's no reward in that also if you
want to have more confidence checking my
254 series it's free the link to join is
in the description below I was reminded
this morning of a question I'm often
asked how do you eliminate theater from
your life so I started to study myself I
found most people don't know who they
are they really don't ask yourself am i
living the way I really want to live
rule number five conquer your own
limitations look at these two men do you
know who they are
most people don't they're just a couple
of ordinary guys one they're both gone
now but one was an ordinary beekeeper in
Auckland New Zealand and the other
Sherpa guide from over around Nepal now
there's Mount Everest you know for
thousands of years people had tried to
get to the top of Mount Everest
people died doing it it was believed it
couldn't be done people tried but they
didn't know how and so they quit there's
a closer look at the mountain and where
they placed their flag they planted that
flag in the mountain now this is the two
of them after they come down the
mountain and you know something when
they started they did not know how they
didn't know how to get to the top of the
mountain and that's what stops most
people because they don't know how as
little kids we'd go mummy daddy I want
this and they say no how are you gonna
do that well as a little kid you don't
know how to do it but they did it in
1953 on the 29th of May they were the
first two to get to the top of that
mountain they stood right on top of the
world do you know there's been over a
thousand people do it since then I
watched a young woman on Canadian
television being interviewed not very
big she had just come back from going to
the top of Mount Everest and the
reporter asked her they said how does it
feel now that you conquered the mountain
she didn't conquer the mountain that
mountain can't be conquered we conquered
the limitations that are within
ourselves rule number six go to experts
for advice select the person who is
already doing something that you'd like
to do get to know that person go to the
experts for advice don't ask the first
nextdoor your mother father brother
the guy works beside you because they
don't necessarily know there's no point
in asking a person how to earn a lot of
money if they're only earning 10,000 a
year they don't know they knew they'd
probably be earning a lot it's like
don't go to a sick doctor if you want to
get healthy okay so you find someone
that you can go to for advice get a real
good book and lock into that book and
start to study it like I bet this one
looks like a Bible you know but this is
napoleon hill's book Think and Grow Rich
I've been reading this thing now for 23
years I'll probably read it for another
23 years I get another good book that I
brought over here today it's called the
power of your subconscious mind and I'm
not getting the Commission for selling
this the author's dead now he's been
gone for a couple of years but dr.
Joseph Murphy wrote this book to power
your subconscious mind and that's
probably one of the best books that
you're ever gonna find because you're
gonna learn something about your mind
when you read this book okay now I read
a lot of books I've got probably a
thousand bucks sitting in my den at home
in my library but the one that I care I
carry it everywhere I go and I read it
all the time just thinking Grow Rich I
never stopped reading it where's the
value for you to reread that rebound I
mean you must you must know it well
enough that I think I could probably
recite it verbatim but the secret is I
once read in the book where it said when
you read a good book through mm-hm the
second time you don't see something in
it that you didn't see before you see
something in yourself that wasn't there
before you see when I read this I
created a greater awareness rule number
seven
don't worry when others think of you you
know many years ago I read a book by
Terry Cole Whitaker it was a classic
what you think of me is none of my
business
think of the amount of time that is
wasted on negative energy wondering what
other people think of you what they
think of you really doesn't make any
difference it's what you think of you
that makes a difference so as you go
through the day don't worry about what
other people think of you just say I'm
all right I'm God's highest form of
creation rule number eight crash through
the terror barrier see this line that's
called the terror barrier yeah
and on the other side of the terror
barrier is something we call freedom and
you know very few people get through
that terror barrier that's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone there
isn't anyone that could not live the way
they want to live saying why don't they
why don't they they don't know and they
don't even know they don't know now I'm
going to show you why people experience
buyer's remorse when they buy something
really want and then they back away
where they going to move and they don't
they go to change jobs they don't they
go to move to another city and they
don't lie
fear causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the X represents
the unknown factor the paradigm now
there's a power flowing into this
individuals mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we had the ability to choose what
do they choose they choose thoughts that
are in harmony with the paradigm now
here's an important point the paradigm
controls the vibration of this thing we
call our body our body is a molecular
instrument that's really what it is it's
a mass of molecules and a very high
speed of vibration the vibration that
the body's in on a conscious level we
call feeling when a person says they
feel this way or they feel that way what
they're really doing is describing the
vibration they're in now they choose
thoughts that harmonize with the
vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable now
let's move ahead let's take a look here
those people are getting X tape results
and they don't like it do you know what
the problem with them they're in bondage
these people are locked up you know
paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison only there's no locks on the door
they can open the prisoner walk out into
freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
over and over again they're in bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person X type conditioning X Tech
vibration the power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from left
field bone in comes a Y type idea what
is the Y type idea the Y type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing it might be
moved to another city changed jobs sell
a house buy the farm whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch go make the sale buy
what you want go where you want to go
that's the Y idea but as long as the Y
idea is just in the conscious mind it's
just going to be an intellectual
exercise it's never going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's
when everything goes haywire here we are
here same person okay the power flows in
now what do they do they got the Y type
idea now for some strange reasons they
know that they've got to get emotionally
involved if they're going to act on that
idea they don't understand what's going
to happen but clearly understand this
your central nervous system is the most
complex electrical system in the
universe the central nervous system is
mind boggling
yet would make the electrical system in
a supercomputer look like a toy now the
second you take the idea from your
intellect and impress it upon the
subject of mind that's when all hell
breaks loose because the body moves in
to an extra X Y vibration it's not in
the X vibration not the one that we're
comfortable with me now like the results
but we're comfortable know on a
conscious level everything's going crazy
on a conscious level we experience dote
the dope turns into an emotion called
fear and that fear is expressed through
the body as anxiety see that person is
getting emotionally involved to move
ahead do you know what happens they hit
that terror barrier and they bounce off
it and right back into bond
and they're so relieved to get back
there they're back where they're
comfortable they've cancelled the sale
they've decided not to move they're
going to stay in the job that they don't
like at least they're comfortable now
that's not a very good way to live and
you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're gonna hit that terror
barrier see the terror barrier is going
beyond where you're at going to a new
level I'm going to tell you something
when I set a goal yep if if it doesn't
scare and excite me at the same time I
know I'm going in the wrong direction
now I also understand that my paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce
back to where I was it doesn't want me
to move ahead I don't want to live there
I lived there for the first 26 years of
my life
and for the last 50 I've had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and I want you to do the
same thing understand what I've just
said I'm gonna back this up there you're
emotionally involved in the why idea
that moved their body into a different
vibration on a conscious level they're
experiencing some crazy stuff they start
to doubt their ability we'll never be
able to pay for it they experience fear
the fear expresses itself as anxiety and
dying you bounce off that terror barrier
and you're right back oh I might not be
earning much here but I know what it is
I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract don't live forever and
they don't you know what to do say I'm
gonna get rid of all that I understand
it's there but I don't want any part of
it and I'm gonna go crashing right
through that terror barrier now does
that get rid of the X energy no that's
energy is still there you see I don't
least your over into freedom you made
the move you did it and if you continue
to feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that Y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're
the road keep doing that you're gonna
find that the paradigm is going to
change and it'll just all go away and
you know you're living in freedom you're
living where you want to live buyer's
remorse is when you cancel a sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's gonna
change your life and you know it it's
not moving to the other city it's not
starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that and if you don't learn to go
through the terror barrier I'm gonna
tell you something you're gonna stay
right where you are for the rest of your
days that's not a good place to be what
did Joseph Campbell say so true they
cave you fear denter holds the treasure
you seek rule number nine develop your
imagination many years ago
I read where Napoleon Hill pointed out
that the imagination is the most
marvelous miraculous in a conceivably
powerful force that the world has ever
known
and Janome the average individual uses
the imagination if they use it at all
against themselves they imagine what
they don't want they imagine problems
going
let's begin to use our imagination the
way God intended to be used it's the
greatest creative faculty that we
possess and we can dump anything we want
want you to wander around your home or
possibly your office and take a look at
all of the conveniences that you have
there
that you didn't have a Satan two years
five years ten years ago 25 years ago do
you know that every one of them without
exception was first created in the mind
of one individual with their imagination
you know you can use your imagination to
go into the future and bring it into the
present that's what all highly
successful people do
they see where they want to go and then
they act like the person they want to
become it was William James from
Harvard's advice he says is the actors
technique act like the person you want
to become how do you do that will you
use your imagination of course to see
it's a strange phenomena but the
greatest gift we've got is used
very well up to the ages of four or
possibly five the little child
we always wonder what's going on in
their mind they're using their
imagination their building wonderful
pictures and their mind but then they
get to school and WHAM like that it
comes to an abrupt halt it's called not
paying attention
daydreaming
well
what they were really doing was
exercising a phenomenal mental faculty
you see we can see hear smell taste
touch therefore our physical benefit as
long as we're living in a physical body
and corresponding with the material
world we will use our sensory factors
but you know I have a couple of little
dogs at home they can hear see smell
taste and touch we've got higher
faculties you have perception the will
memory intuition reason and imagination
these marvelous tools
we can take our imagination and build an
image in our mind of how we want to live
block out what's going now don't let
your present results have anything to do
with this just what you want
and it's with your imagination that you
will build
everything that we have the camera that
I'm speaking to right now was first
created in the mind of one individual
think of how our worlds changed you see
we were gifted with these higher
faculties we're God's highest form of
creation we were created in God's image
we were given creative faculties to use
and you know they're only used by two or
three percent of the population it's
almost inconceivable that would people
would wander around with so much power
and potential and squadron
see the average person literally tiptoes
through life who think they make it
safely to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way
Sequoyah giant corporations and little
weed creative departments the primary
reason for that is the average
individual really does not believe that
there
everyone's created and no one is more
creative than another it's just that
some have chosen to use their creative
faculties to a greater degree than
others
[Music]
imagination your imagination what do you
want how do you really want to live
build the picture in your mind there's a
power that is flowing to and through you
a creative unadulterated power it can be
photographed leaving your body
way back in the 37 curly in the russian
photographer perfected apartment
photography we can actually photograph a
person's body and you will see the
energy glowing from them well that
energy flows into your mind and it's the
images you build in your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration that this
instrument you're living in is in and
the vibration on the conscious level is
called feeling make certain that you
exercise your imagination daily build
beautiful images in your mind of how you
want to live and then hold those
pictures there and live that way the
imagination the greatest nation in the
world the imagination
you've got one
it's a marvelous creative tool
it deals with the invisible side of your
personality you see no one will ever
really see you they'll only see your
body and they'll see you the great work
that you do make certain that your work
is great work and if you keep your
imagination alive you're gonna have a
phenomenal life you know life can get
better every day and it will get better
every day
through the proper use
of your imagination
what a wonderful
rule number ten changed the paradigm do
you know that the law of attraction is
always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's gonna go
down it's never gonna go back up it's
gonna go down that is law of gravity
anything heavier than Earth is attracted
towards the center of the world well the
law of attractions always working now
how does it work well I use a diagram to
explain the mind now let this circle
represent your mind and let this little
circle here represent your body now I
want you to think of this for a moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a mass of energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next twenty years when
you move out of it the body does not
stop moving if you go to a funeral
parlor and pick up the remains and look
at it you will see it moving and if it
wasn't moving how would it ever change
the dust you move into your body and you
will move up and it's how you use your
mind that's gonna dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me you have an
imaginary line right across here and
that separates the conscious mind from
the subconscious mind now the
subconscious mind has been programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there and all the energy
that went in there when you were just a
little baby form something called a
paradigm now a paradigm is information
it's a multitude of habits you are the
product of your environment but prior to
that you are the product of a genetic
strain that goes back for generations
now I'm going to say that the paradigm
is x-type energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think and as
you think you build ideas there's a
power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you now as it flows
in you will start thinking and you'll
probably think X type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an X
type vibration and that will produce X
type results now it's the results you
want to change and to change the results
you're gonna have to change what you
attract to see the thoughts that you
think control the vibration that you're
in vibration is nothing but an idea it's
a law of the universe everything
vibrates nothing rest we live in an
ocean of motion and it's the thoughts
that you're thinking that you impress
upon your subconscious mind that control
the vibration the bodies in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract you attract
energy that's in harmony with you you
attract people that are in harmony with
you you see everything operates on
frequencies there's an infinite number
of frequencies but you and I operate on
the frequency just like a radio station
does and the only music you can attract
is the music that is tuned into the
vibration you're in now it's the
paradigm that has been controlling the
vibration you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you got to
change the paradigm and if you don't
change the paradigm nothing happens now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a Y type thought
which is totally different than the X
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere because when you go to get them
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white tape done the paradigm
will kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable that's stepping out of the
box that's doing things different and we
don't like to do things different
because it causes a lot of discomfort
but understand this the paradigm and the
thinking control the vibration you're in
then the vibration is going to dictate
what you attract people that are in a
poverty consciousness will continue to
attract black and limitation it has
nothing to do with this what's going on
here this is you're educated mind and
you could gather all kinds of
information have you ever wondered why
some people have such an educated mind
they have degrees coming right off the
end of their business card but it
doesn't show up in their results why
paradigm
the law of attraction you've got to
change this you've got to change the
vibration you're in and your whole world
changes listen in 1961 a man gave me
this book and he said do exactly what I
tell you he was giving me why type ideas
it caused an enormous amount of
discomfort but I did exactly what he
said and you know something my income
went from a four thousand one hundred
and seventy five thousand in a year and
then I took it over a million it took me
nine and a half years to figure out what
happened this is what I'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here and
another lesson I'm going to show you how
to change the paradigm when you change
the paradigm the change in results is
automatic you know what you start to
attract something there something
different and what we want to do is
program in positive information and
eliminate the negative I'm going to show
you how to do a lot of attraction you
attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera in a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good
we're in a negative vibration I want to
feel good move into a positive vibration
stop and think of what you're grateful
for but understand this you will never
attract to you wealth happiness health
until you get the paradigm and get you
on that frequency
it's about Proctor and thank you rule
number 11 change yourself see people
don't resist change people resist being
changed
hey yes we've got to change yourself
we've got to build a new image a picture
in our mind we've got to see yourself
the way we want to be and then we have
to live with it that's you go to the gym
workout that's what you do you build a
picture of how you want to see this arm
disarm and you build that picture and
then
you build the body while you build the
life in your mind take your pen and
write out how you want to live and
always start by writing I'm so happy and
grateful now that and the second you
write it you've got it intellectually
the moment you impress it upon your
emotional mind you've got it emotionally
and it's only a period of time till it
manifests on the physical plane
yeah spirit works from a higher to a
lower potential rule number 12 expand
your awareness let that little yellow
dot on the screen represent your level
of awareness this represents your level
of awareness this is what you're aware
of now everything you've got in your
life everything your relationships your
money everything is an expression of
your own level of awareness see people
that are in fifty thousand a year or not
earning fifty because they want 50
people are earning fifty because they're
not aware of how to earn 150 people that
are suffering from headaches they're not
suffering headaches because they want to
suffer from headaches they're suffering
from headaches because they're not aware
of how to eliminate the headache it's
their head they made it eight they can
make it stop
so you see it's awareness where after
now think of this if that little dot
represents our awareness and it's
responsible for everything we've got in
life just think of how your life could
change if we magnify it just a little
bit I mean everything would start to
change our relationships would change we
would be healthier we would live in
healthier bodies we would know more
people we'd earn more money we'd be able
to do more interesting things and if we
just increased it a little bit more
everything starts to shift well I've
been living this way now for 40 years it
absolutely fascinating I celebrated my
70th birthday last week I got more
energy than most people 20 I have
absolutely no intentions of slowing down
people said say you should slow down
that's a bunch of crap we should speed
up we've got more power yeah do you know
the the most erudite scientists alive
can't even guess what you and I are
capable of doing no one knows what we're
capable of all the powers on the present
that's within you within me
slow down we're just starting to warm up
what we want to do is calm down
you can go out warp speed and stay very
healthy if you stay relaxed and that's
really the secret you know just imagine
we expand our awareness a little more do
you know what this program is doing for
you today it's expanding your awareness
that's what the program is all about
every time you come every time you come
to one of these programs your awareness
is widened your world starts to change
you think oh yeah that's pretty
interesting and it just keeps getting
bigger and bigger and bigger our
awareness keeps changing do you know
that no one knows how much money you're
capable of earning there's no one can
even guess at what you're capable of
earning we want to become aware we're
like we are because we're not aware of
how to do it better we know how to do it
better every person in this room
intellectually knows how to do a better
job than they're doing everyone in the
room knows how to earn more than they're
earning but they're not doing it you see
having the knowledge is not the deal
having the knowledge I mean when I
remember when I was a kid
schoolteachers say to me Bob why'd you
do that I'd say I don't know well what
do you mean you don't know you know
better I know why did you do I don't
know I was in the Navy every commanding
officer Proctor why did you do that I
don't know sir
what do you mean you don't know you know
better I know why'd you do it I don't
know you see I didn't know why I was
doing things do you know that we do
things that we don't want to do it gives
us results we don't want to get yet we
do them anyway you know what addiction
is it's never getting enough of what you
don't want again a lot of people are
addicted to results that they don't want
why do we keep doing it
you see I think when we start to see
that that's when we start to become
aware of how to take control over our
life and that's really what we want to
do so do you see awareness is the big
deal we want to become aware of the
obvious opportunities that are available
to us we are surrounded
by opportunity there everywhere you go
there is an abundance there's no
shortage of opportunity we can win and
we can win in a big way now when we lack
awareness we miss the opportunity I used
to always say that you know the trick is
to be in the right place at the right
time I've been in the right place at the
right time many times in my life but I
blew it you know why I wasn't aware that
I was in the right place of the right I
had to look back at it think of it
there's something else it's being aware
that you're in the right place at the
right times not good enough you've got
to be aware that you're in the right
place at the right time rule number 13
replace that bad habit with a good habit
habits good habits will give you results
that stick bad habits will destroy
everything I have some bad habits that's
right all my habits are not great so if
you've got some bad habits don't feel
bad so does your next-door neighbor so
does your mentor your coach so does your
mother and father if they're alive so
does everyone and the trick of life is
to replace a bad habit with a good habit
I used to hang around bars all the time
and one day I went in and I picked up a
glass and I looked around and I thought
they're all bums in here and then it
dawned on me I'm always here I learned
something I put the glass down I said
I'm never coming back here again
and I'm never gonna drink this and I
never did it was a long time ago but you
know what I did I went from spending all
my money in the bar to a racetrack and I
started to bet it all on horses so I
went from making somebody with a bar get
wealthy and then I started to feed the
horses and one day I woke up and I
learned something if you don't
consciously and deliberately replace a
bad habit with a good habit you will
automatically create another bad habit
now what is a habit a habit is an idea
that has been planted in the garden of
your subconscious mind and then
repetitively fed for a sufficient period
of time that you act on it without
giving any thought to it I'll give you
I want you to right now mentally imagine
you're pulling on your underwear in the
morning what what do you put in first I
put my right foot in if I tried to put
my left foot in my underwear first I'd
stagger and I'd fall over let me say
what's this got to do with it it's got
everything to do with it why do I put my
right foot you may put your left
certainly a lot of people do well when I
was just a little gapper didn't have a
clue of how to put underwear on my
mother or my grandmother and my father
or somebody came along and they had the
underwear ad put your foot in here
you're rather [ __ ] what did they do they
had the underwear prepared as if they
were gonna put it on and so pretty soon
I was doing it like they were doing it
they through repetition planted the idea
in my hand in my mind well now think of
this
you don't just form habits of how to get
dressed you form habits to do everything
that you do and some of them are not
that productive any idea that you keep
dwelling on and impressing upon your
subconscious mind becomes fixed in the
subconscious mind
a habit is nothing but an idea that's
fixed in the subconscious mind that you
act on without giving any conscious
thought many years ago I went in to
train the Prudential Insurance Company
of America their agents I ended up
training all of their agents and I only
got them to do two things this is in the
early 70s I got them to form the habit
of being in front of a prospect before
9:00 a.m. and asked everybody they
talked to to purchase $100,000 worth of
insurance I said you don't have to sell
them just give them the opportunity to
say no you know the sales in that
company went up by hundreds of millions
of dollars i de rewire a retired VP tell
me he thought it was a billion just
change in two habits what habit you want
to change I'm forever checking out
habits I've got I'm in the habit right
now of changing my diet and you know
something I've been doing it for going
on three weeks it's getting easier but
it's still not that easy I'd still like
to reach over and eat some of that
when nobody's luck it doesn't work
doesn't work I'm looking
what habit are you gonna form and you
shouldn't drive for more than two it
once it'll become too big and too heavy
and you won't form any make up your mind
you're gonna do it every day every day
every day until you don't have to think
about it and then you'll automatically
do it I guarantee you this idea will
change your life think about it all day
because that is definitely an idea that
will give you results that will stick
rule number fourteen surround your mind
with greatness right now I'm standing in
the middle of my library this is my
favorite place to know Earl and you'll
see it if you surround your mind with
greatness
some of us gonna rub off well hopefully
some of it has rubbed off on me I have
maybe three or four thousand books here
on the shelf they're all in alphabetical
order by author they're all catalogued
so I know where to find something just
like that I go by authors more than the
title of the book do you know that when
I started studying these books I really
didn't know very much about anything I
had two months high school I was 26
years old a bad work record a bad
attitude and and virtually no experience
and you know in a relatively short
period of time my income went from four
thousand one hundred and seventy five
thousand a year then we're over a
million rule number 15
be honest with yourself I'm going to
share some information with you that it
could change the direction of your life
like night and day and when I say that I
want you to really stop and take a look
at your life take an honest look at your
life I was thinking just before I start
to make this we have actually been
conditioned to kid with ourselves to lie
to ourselves to not really take an
honest look at the results we're getting
I want you to take a real honest look at
your results and when you look at them
ask yourself am i living the way I
really want to live you see most people
aren't one of the first questions I ask
a person that comes to work with me
I want to know what's the most they've
ever earned in a year now I really don't
care what the answer is but I want to
know what the answer is because you see
if if a person says the most I've ever
earned in years $50,000 I know where
their mind is programmed if they tell me
the most they've ever earned is two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars I
know where they're programmed and then I
want to find out what they want and I
know then what has to shift because
their mind is programmed and if they're
really going to live the way they want
to live they they've got to change the
program and if they don't change the
program then nothing really happens rule
number 16 get into the success zone I
want to suggest that you make up your
mind you're going to get in what we call
the success zone yes it's a way of
thinking now get this yeah 95 96 percent
of the population are blowing it yep one
percent of the population are earning
about 95 percent of all the money you're
not going to get a whole lot of people
agree with what you're doing most people
are going to look at you're kind of
strange what are you going there for you
weren't there last month what are you
listening to that for you listen to that
before what are you reading it what do
you read the same book over and over for
they don't understand and you see
they're advertising their ignorance by
the questions they ask when we get into
the success zone everything in our life
starts to change but understand this
you're going to be a bit of a nod you're
out of the box you're not one of the
masses and then you get out of the box
your whole world starts to shift rule
number 17 be a leader there's a box and
there's a leader leader get people
excited about improving the quality of
whatever it is themselves their work
whatever they're doing people follow
leaders because they want to people
don't follow our leaders because they
have to that becomes a form of
dictatorship yeah and that never works
the great leaders people want to follow
and leaders inspired leaders pull the
very bust out of you leader
know how to look inside and bring the
best of you to the service cause you to
look at the higher side of your own
personality what the world always is
looking for its leader like it it's
silly - who's gonna lead the leaders
gonna lead and the leader just
automatically emerges if they threw 50
of us into a committee and say you don't
elect a leader you may elect one but the
leaders gonna leading it probably isn't
the one that's elected yeah yeah so true
knows oh they know how to get the best
out of people
rule number 18 know where you're going I
want to talk to you about where you're
going and what you want to do with your
life you see most people never go after
what they want because they don't know
every step they have to take to get
there I want you to think of a person
going up the side of a wall of ice now
the only rule for reaching a goal that
you have to know is knowing where you're
going and knowing that you're going to
get there you do not have to know how
you're going to get there now pay
attention to this for a moment imagine
the climber has all his equipment he's
got his crampons he's got his climbing
rope his hardware his ice access how
does he get to the top he's standing on
the ground and he's looking at maybe a
hundred foot vertical wall of ice he
looks up and he has absolutely no idea
the path that he's going to take he just
sees himself at the top he reaches up
and he puts one pick in and then another
pick then he raises one foot and then
the other now he's not standing on the
ground any longer he's suspended on the
wall on a vertical wall of ice that goes
up for a hundred feet he adapts to the
changes that is taking place in his
environment and then and only then does
he see the next step and he moves this
then this pic then this foot then this
foot now that's how he gets to the top a
step at a time
and that's how you're going to get to
your goal you just have to know the
first step to take and when you take
that step you're going to find that your
conditions your circumstance and
environment will change then you see how
you have to make the next step it's a
matter of adapting all the time you only
have to know two things you have to know
where you're going and you have to know
that you're going to get there you've
got to see it in your mind now this is
the beautiful scenario this is what it's
all about
save that in your mind and think of it
often think every time you think of your
goal and you're trying to figure out how
you're gonna do it think of that
vertical wall of ice what's the next
step that's all you really have to know
one step at a time and you'll get to
wherever you're going that's how Hillary
got to the top of Mount Everest
rule number 19 be open-minded in
Napoleon Hills walk
thank you grow rich he said now right
here we come to a rather strange fact we
tend to minimize the things we can do
the Gulf's we can accomplish and for
some equally strange reason we think
other people can accomplish things that
we cannot any points out that there's a
difference between wishing for a thing
and being ready to receive them said no
one's ready for a thing until they
believe that they can acquire it the
state of mind must be belief and not
mere hope or wish now it was like the
consciousness ease and open-mindedness
is essential to belief closed minds will
not inspire faith courage orderly rule
number 20 be willing to do what is
required a German engineer by the name
of Karl Benz at a fantasy and he
literally turned his fantasy into a fact
and in January 1886 Karl Benz was issued
a patent for the Benz motor carriage and
the age of the automobile had done this
is a replica of that magnificent machine
and you know before Benz ever turned his
fantasy into a theory even long
certainly long before he turned it into
a fact he had asked him
self a couple of questions that you and
I and every other dreamer will have to
go through he had to ask himself am i
able to do this well he seemed to have
that innate awareness of this higher
self this image of perfection within him
and he saw himself as a person that was
actually able to take and turn the
fantasy into effect now he must have
been a pretty courageous guy because
there were no horseless carriages in
those days but then he had to ask
himself am I willing and you see he had
asked himself am I willing to accept the
ridicule that I'm bound to get am I
willing to accept the failures well he
said yes I am willing he was willing to
pay the ultimate price to turn his
fantasy into a fact and ridicule he got
his own partner thought he had gone mad
and he had to find himself a more
congenial colleague to work with he
would take this thing out in the evening
he'd take it out at night so no one
would see him he escapes some of the
ridicule and time after time he couldn't
get it going he had to push it back but
it never dawned on him that he would not
ultimately realize his dream when this
magnificent machine completed its first
long journey with bends of the wheel
every beat of the engine found an
answering echo in the heart of the
driver as every turn of the wheels
brought him closer to his goal to the
realization of what once was a fantasy
now in order for you to turn your
fantasies into a fact you have to go
through exactly the same process as Karl
Benz and if you do go through the same
process you'll meet with exactly the
same success regardless of the
opposition you might come up against you
have to ask am I able to turn this
fantasy of mine into a fact can I
actually realize it can I turn my dreams
into reality now you're either going to
say yes I'm able to or no I'm not if you
realize you are able if you have an
understanding of this potential this
power within you then you have to ask
yourself are you willing and there's a
long series of tests there you don't
even know what you're going to come up
again
one thing is for certain you'll come up
against ridicule you may have to move
you may have to do all kinds of things
that you don't even think about you have
to be willing to do whatever is required
if you really want to turn your fantasy
into a fact the second you say yes I am
willing at that instant you've created
your theory
rule number 21 act on your ideas hello
there and welcome
do you know almost everyone has a great
idea and they're going to execute the
great idea I have all kinds of people
come to me I've got a great idea I'd
like to share with you what they do is
they want me to execute their idea why
don't they execute their idea when you
get a real good idea you should act on
it people have ideas as starting a
business I've started a number of
different businesses question is where
to start you start where you are and you
start with what you've got
that's all you need when you start where
you are and with what you've got
and you bring your mind to focus on that
idea you will attract everything to you
that you need you are taught see key
first is Kingdom in its righteousness
and all these things will be given to us
see when you learn to focus on something
you get on a frequency and when you're
in that frequency you start to attract
whatever you want you may not have any
money you may not have the resources
that you need to execute to build it
into something big that doesn't matter
all the resources that you need to do
anything you want to do is already here
but you've got to get in touch with them
you've got to get in harmony with them
and boom you'll rush them into your life
you'll attract the money the people the
thoughts the things everything you need
you'll attract to you so where do you
start you always start where you are and
you start with what you've got
don't be looking at what you don't have
think of what you do have fall in love
with your idea and get it rolling
rule number 22 believe you tell yourself
a lie often enough you're gonna start to
believe it and way around 1900 William
James said believe and your belief will
create the fact
it's got to be believed you've got to
believe it and if there's no belief it
ain't gonna happen
see when you believe it you're encased
in the idea you fuse with the idea and
that makes all kinds of things happen
when you believe it there's no quitting
you never quit it doesn't matter what
happens you don't quit quitting is never
an option I the people that quit they
never really bought into the idea in the
first place
see you've got it you you get it on
three levels the second you think of
something you've got it intellectually
when you get emotionally involved you've
got it on a spiritual or emotional level
well then that expresses itself through
the body but it's just an instrument of
your mind
and so when you're really buying into it
you literally fuse with it Neville said
you fuse with it and this causes all
kinds of things to happen you're dealing
with electronics you're dealing with
energy like the second you think
something that's all you need see you
live on frequencies you think on
frequencies your phone operates on
frequencies and it's like magic and
you're you're in Romania is right I'm in
Toronto yes if I've got your number on
my phone I could take a picture
something hit it like that you've got it
in Romania simultaneous with me sending
it because when you get into the mind
there isn't any time or space it's just
immediate yeah well the you're living on
frequencies now when you think of
something what you've done is you
flipped your brain onto a higher
frequency
the very fact you can see it is all the
proof you need to know you could get it
what you have to do is raise your level
of consciousness to that frequency and
then you will attract whatever is on
that frequency all the good you need to
manifest the idea rule number 23
overcome fear overcoming fear is
one of the greatest moves a person can
make first of all we have to ask
yourself what causes fear fears caused
by ignorance not knowing and if we're
gonna go and do anything new if we're
gonna break out of a paradigm if we're
gonna change habit patterns we're
wandering into an area we've never been
and you know fear stops most people
you'll find people afraid to talk to a
stranger you'll find individuals afraid
to stand up and ask the question in
front of other people
you'll find salespeople afraid to make a
sales call afraid to ask for the order
stop and think of how confining that is
a person is putting themself into a
small cell but it's in their own mind
the doors aren't locked they can open
and you can walk away to free them if
you learn to overcome fear when you face
fear it leaves you face the thing you
fear and it'll leave you that's really
the secret of it in fact if you hold
yourself back because of fear your life
actually comes to a stop because nothing
gets better than it is you've got to be
courageous
now Crete just people aren't without
fear courageous people are the ones that
face their fear I think Eddie
Rickenbacker pointed that out the great
pilot
don't let fear stop you make up your
mind you're gonna step out and do it
stop and think of the number of people
that are in jobs that they don't like
and they're afraid to leave or people in
relationships that are destructive and
they're afraid to leave this is a
terrible way to live and it's not
necessary it's just caused by ignorance
and when we step out and do something we
gain in their awareness we develop an
understanding and like that the fear is
gone make up your mind
that fear it's not going to stop you
from doing the thing you really want to
do step out and do it today rule number
24 visualize and when I was 26 I had a
man
that sat down with me and he said why
don't you change the way you're living
it never entered my mind that I could
and looking back and thinking about it I
think there's all kinds of people
wandering the planet there's all kinds
of athletes they're not getting the
results they want and they don't know
they can change them but only one person
can say there's only one person in the
whole universe that can change Bob and
that's Bob yeah there's only one person
can change Dave in that state now we get
inspired by other people we get help
from other people but we've got to do it
ourself and he gave me thinking for rich
and he said if you do exactly what I
tell you you can have anything you want
well I didn't believe that but he was so
adamant about I believed he believed and
so I started to listen to him and I set
a goal I wanted some money
I wanted 25,000 hours you know this was
in 1961 so it was more money than it is
today but I didn't even know anyone with
$25,000 he said listen write it on a
card keep reading the book keep doing
what I tell you so I started to hear
people talking about earning money and
there was one guy said there's good
money cleaning floors you should usually
clean floors well I wasn't proud I'd
clean floors and he said but you should
do it for yourself not for somebody else
so he told me where I could buy a use
for him in some buckets and mops but I
had to borrow a thousand dollars well I
was at the farmer nobody wanted to touch
it with money and I often say I wouldn't
have lend it to me right because I
wouldn't pay it back not that I didn't
want to I just couldn't but I found a
guy he lent me $2,000 when you borrow I
have questions I know you when you
borrow that that thousand because you
owed people money already you explained
that to people you know you were just
finding yourself but did you have a
different feeling about when you
borrowed this thousand that quite
possibly you were actually gonna be able
to pay this back this time you know
something if I hadn't had that feeling I
wouldn't have got the money I got it
from a guy I knew his name al Kuiper he
was running and I didn't know him he had
a trust company it was like a bank
on Danforth Avenue in Toronto and I went
in I read a book where it says go to one
bank of him with giving Gordon another
one well I ended up sitting in his
office and he said what do you want this
money for son and I told him I was gonna
build a cleaning company it was gonna be
big I had a dream and I had to explain
it alter he said I think you'll do it
I'm gonna lend you the money
faith but I knew when I was doing this I
had a picture I had a dream you see yep
and within a year I was earning a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars a year i had my building up to
$15,000 a month working for myself less
than five years we were working in
Toronto Montreal Boston Cleveland
Atlanta and London England I had my own
company off opening offices all over the
place rule number 25 know what you want
why most people don't get what they want
out of life is it well they don't know
what they want that's right you see I
got this and then I got a row
Nightingale's condensed narration of
this on the long playing record and I'd
listened that record over and over and
over again one day I was in the business
the only cleaning business I had
salespeople and I had them listen to
this record every morning we listen to
this record and one day I said you know
I'd love to meet him
and I didn't know who or a light yo was
he was a voice on a record that was it I
didn't even know where he lived and a
young guy that worked with me he said no
you wouldn't he's if you wanted to meet
him you'd go and meet him I thought damn
he's right
so I phoned and I got an appointment
with him now at the time he was the most
listened to man in the history of the
broadcasting industry he was a radio
broadcaster and not an easy guy to get
to but I got to meet with him for an
hour I flew to Chicago I spent an hour
with them and when I was leaving I said
Earl what's the big deal
you know I mean what's it all about he
says there's no big deal
he said it's it's very simple he says
simply decide what you love to do and
then dedicate your life to it he's the
problem with most people they don't know
what they love to do they never take the
time to sit and ask themselves what
they're doing is trying to I think I can
get her and good money here I could do
it good you know it's Rickon the earn
some money it's not what they love to do
well I was sitting there you know I had
offices all over the place I had a lot
of people I was earning a lot of money
and I I got excited because I knew
exactly what I want to do I'm gonna do
what he was doing and I made up my mind
sitting in his office and be somewhere
around 1965 then I was gonna go back and
I was gonna work with him and in 1968 I
moved to Chicago I left my own company I
moved to Chicago when they started to
work with him
rule number 26 be more patient here
patience is a virtue
I suppose it probably is but I think
patience real patience is an expression
of deep understanding to see everything
happens when it's supposed to happen
everything in this universe happens by
law we set targets and we need things to
happen we need something to come or
someone to do something and frequently
we get frustrated because it isn't
happening when we think it should happen
our problem is we're not thinking we
believe we're in charge we are not in
charge we are in charge of building the
idea and holding the idea every
else happens automatic it happens by law
all ideas have a gestation or an
incubation period I'm told when we plant
a carrot in the area of the world that I
live it takes approximately seven days
for that carrot to grow and manifest in
form when the seed for the babies
planted it takes approximately 280 days
and we're usually patient we will wait
the 280 days why because we know it's
going to take approximately 280 days
well just because we don't know how long
it's going to take doesn't mean that it
isn't operating by the same laws
everything operates by law so if we cane
and understanding that all the ideas in
our mind will ultimately move into form
that's what Andrew Carnegie taught
Napoleon Hill Carnegie was Hill's mentor
he said any idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered but begin it wants to close
itself in the most convenient and
appropriate form available you might
want to listen to that two or three
times burn it into your mind gain an
understanding of it and you will know
that whatever you're working on takes a
period of time no one knows what the
gestation period is for an idea
we only know we can shorten it through
concentration through focus and when you
understand that they'll become more
patient and when you're more patient and
living in a much more beautiful
vibration you'll be a more pleasant
person to be around
you will enjoy yourself patients it's
the result of understanding rule number
27 tap into your genius if you really
analyze your beliefs you'll change them
I had a friend one time I I was trying
to figure out where do beliefs come from
how do you because all religion and all
science will tell you you got to believe
it William James from Harvard 1900 he
said believe in your belief will create
the fact so belief is an interesting
word you got to believe it
[Music]
I was having lunch with a mentor one
time and he said our belief system is
based upon our evaluation of something
frequently if we reevaluate a situation
our belief about that situation will
change it was like bells were going off
my head because I was trying to
understand belief how do you change your
belief well he told me yes through
revaluation and so I started to evaluate
myself and reevaluate what I was doing
it took me nine and a half years but I
figured out why I changed and it was the
repetition of information thank you
you're in sports you know it's
repetition yep repetition repetition
well but practice doesn't make you
perfect perfect practice makes you
perfect there's a big difference great
point and so I found that the part of
our mind that controls our behavior is
not the part of our mind that gathers
information school deals with the part
of your mind that gathers information
and so we gather all kinds of
information and if we can remember it
they give us a test we pass the test we
get that degree and we're educated
that's not education at all that is
gathering information education as he'll
pointed out comes from the Latin adieu
co-main is reduced to developer to drug
from within
we have genius in us we have absolute
perfection in us and what we have to do
is learn how to tap into that to let it
out but we have a part of our mind that
controls our behavior and that's where a
paradigm is and the paradigm literally
controls our behavior I don't care what
you're doing if you not altering the
paradigm
you're not going to improve your results
there's so much about ourselves we never
learn the part of our mind that controls
us is our intellect our subconscious
where the paradigm is but we're trained
to live through our senses we're trained
to go by what we see hear smell taste
touch and we've got to understand that
we've got this genius within us and if
we will consciously gain an awareness
and understanding of how to alter the
paradigm that's controlling our behavior
when we learn that we can start to
improve life just like that
and there's no end to what we're capable
of doing we're conditioned genetically
all mums DNA and all dad's DNA becomes
our DNA there's two particles of energy
come together that's the moment of
conception 280 days later we make our
debut on the planet them were programmed
by our environment because our
subconscious mind which is totally
deductive it has no ability to reject
the subconscious mind is amoral it's
like the earth it doesn't care what you
plant but it'll return what your planned
role meant Gail used a beautiful example
in the strangest secret he said you can
plant nightshade a deadly poison not
1/16 of an inch away
you can plant corn and sweet food one
will grow with just as great an
abundance as the other and that's the
way your subjective mind works you put
the wrong idea in it will grow put the
right idea and it will grow we have the
ability to change what's in there we did
not program it it was programmed through
genetic history where the confluence of
a genetic pool occurs back for
generations that's at birth and then
environmentally and we have the ability
to alter all that rule number 28 get
good mentors see any success I've had
I've had because I've got great mentors
and I'm a good student now until I was
26 I was a terrible student when I
picked up this book I become a great
student I've got thousands of bucks I
have an office at home in my home it's
got a couple of thousand books in it and
I built a studio and I've got a couple
of thousand bucks in the studio I love
reading
but the success that I've enjoyed is
because of the mentors or the coaches
I've had I would do exactly what they
tell me and if I coach somebody today
and they don't do exactly what I tell
them I don't coach them anymore just
like that it's all over it's not ready
well they're not there it's not that
only that they're not ready but if I'm
gonna coach somebody and they're not
doing what I tell them I'm wasting my
time and and theirs too now if they want
to waste their time that's their
prerogative I'm not gonna waste my rule
number 29 practice forgiveness you know
forgiving is one of the most freeing
concept anybody can ever get involved
with most people look at forgiveness as
helping the other person somebody hurts
you somebody does you're wrong but
you're gonna forgive them you're gonna
be kind to them it is nothing to do with
the other person it has to do with
yourself that's really what it has to do
see forgiveness is a cleansing concept
it's clearing the mind of all negativity
clearing the mind of anything that might
go wrong it's a very freeing concept if
you were to do some harm to me and I
forgive you you haven't got anything to
do with it
it's I'm letting go of something that
was bothering me that's negative and I
don't want to hold on to that forgiving
freeze the one that's doing the
forgiving it's a phenomenal concept
forgive me to let go of completely
abandoned let it go don't hold on to it
Joe somebody does you're wrong you have
to ask themself ask yourself wonder why
they would do that there's something
bothering them they're not really trying
to hurt you
it's something that's bothering that let
it go just forgive it forgive the idea
and I guarantee you you'll feel a lot
better
rule number 30 developed confidence and
one of the greatest hang-ups that people
have is the belief in themselves they
they suffer from something called
self-doubt many years ago I read
something it was by um Ralph Waldo
Emerson it was this essay on
self-reliance that's what we want to do
we want to rely on self and in that he
said there would come a time in every
person's education when they realized
that envy is ignorance and imitation is
suicide so many people look at someone
that's doing very well possibly in the
same field they're in and envy them do
you know what that's saying that's
saying I don't know that I have the same
mental faculties you've got I'm drawing
on the same potential that you're
drawing on there is only one mind I
don't know that so I'm gonna envy you
thinking you can do something I'm not
able to do the truth is if you can do it
I can do it
envy is ignorance it's not knowing that
and he said imitation is suicide do you
know that nothing in this universe would
move in the precise order it moves in
your absence
that's true everything in the universe
is essential you take any part away from
anything it's not complete and
everything in the universe moves in a
very precise way so do you see we
shouldn't even want to be like anybody
else because we are unique we are truly
unique there's something like about us
then you'll never find in another person
were unique and we've got the godlike
ability to think now what is self-doubt
self-doubt is the opposite of
self-confidence confidence comes from
understanding like I would imagine
you're confident you can drive your car
in fact you're so confident that you'll
be talking to somebody on the phone
you'll get in the car you'll start the
car you'll Drive and your
right maybe four or five blocks not even
be unaware of what you've done it's all
done automatic your concentration is on
the conversation you're on now when you
first got in a car you couldn't do that
the car was probably jumping all over
the place and you thought you'd never
learned how to drive it but you learned
how to drive it now you're quite
confident you're confident that you can
get dressed when you get up in the
morning when you're a little boy or a
little girl you couldn't do that you had
to be taught to do it well you know self
confidence comes like all confidence it
comes with knowledge and the more you
study you the more you understand who
you are the more confident you'll become
in your ability to do whatever it is
you're doing and you'll know that if you
like confidence in an area it's because
you liked information in that area never
doubt yourself and when you do
understand that the cause of that doubt
is not lying within you it's in wrong
thinking it's you not understanding who
you are
study yourself self study will develop
self confidence and self confidence
eliminates self doubt
rule number 31 move into action you know
Don Shula they coach of the old my Miami
Dolphins he said it's the start that
stops most people and he's right it is
to start the stops most people they're
always gonna get ready to get set to get
going what we've got to do is boom just
like that move into action see if you
don't get started you're never gonna get
finished how do we do that start early I
believe when you wake up you should get
up the second you wake up get your feet
hit the floor move into action and you
know you'd be wise if you sit down at
night before you go to bed and write
down six goal achieving activities
now that doesn't go to the store go to
the bank or get to cleaning it's not
that these are goal achieving activities
write down six of them and when you wake
up in the morning you move into action
you know where you're gonna go you don't
even have to think about it step in
actually get on the first one when you
get it done forget it and go to the
second one don't think about the first
one focus on - don't even think about
three
get to done go to three but not come off
one at a time if you don't get them all
done just move them over on to the next
day and that doesn't mean if you only
get three done that you have nine the
next day there are three of the six that
you're gonna do the next day six goal
achieving activities and when you wake
up in the morning move into action on
them quit holding yourself back don't
wait and say well I really don't know
how I'm going to get started and the way
will show itself it just appears I have
found when you get started when you move
into action everything starts to happen
around you
rule number 32 have a strong why I have
worked all over the world I mean all
over Asia China South America and North
America Europe and I'm always asking
people what do you really want and I
have found most people don't want to be
really wealthy what they do want is they
don't want to have any financial
concerns if they want to bind their suit
they can go and get one if they want to
take a trip they can take the trip if
they want a new car they can get the new
car they want to just run out and spend
or buy they don't want to have any
financial concerns to they want to wake
up in the morning excited about how
they're gonna spend their day and the
third they want to mix with people who
are upbeat and creatively productive
these are the three things that people
really want so in answer to your
question if somebody's watching what's
the first thing they should do well the
first thing they should do is understand
why we have goals not just to set a goal
because most people don't set goals
right they they're operating with a
limited level of consciousness so
they're thinking hmm if I could get a
little more money and if I could get him
to help me and her to help me and this
happened then I could do this
maybe this is get a new car but we kind
of understand these we're treating our
life for our goals literally trading our
life would you trade your life for a car
or a house I don't think so so it's got
to be something really meaningful and
we're not taught to think this way we
should sit down and don't give any
thought to where the money is gonna come
from where the help is gonna come from
it's what do you really want like Ed
Hillary was a beekeeper in Auckland
that's right he wanted to climb Mount
Everest it had never been done great
people died trying to do it he went in
51 and failed he went back in 52 and
failed in 1953 he stood and talked to
the mountain with Tenzing Norgay
but he didn't know how to get there
until after he had got there Edison
didn't know how to illuminate the world
until after he had done it the Wright
brothers were bicycle mechanics in
Dayton Ohio no one believed he could fly
they'd been trying it for years but they
saw it but they wanted to do it they
didn't know how and they couldn't tell
you until after they had done it now the
first flight only lasted 12 seconds and
the naysayers said yeah but they only
were up there for 12 seconds
they said we not only got up there we
kept the damn thing up there for 12
seconds so when a person sets a goal
they've got to say look what I want if I
just let my mind roar off just wander
use my imagination how do I really want
to live that's what they should be doing
rule number 33 start with a vision most
people don't use their imagination
constructively most people use their
imagination destructively they imagine
what they don't want we've got to
consciously and deliberately imagine
what we do want if we will take and sit
down with a pen
and ask yourself what do I really want
what do I really want and write it down
and then make a written description of
it in the present tense
writing causes thinking thinking creates
an image and you get these images going
you're building a vision in your mind
it's the visionaries that's changed the
world
think of that the fact that I can sit
and look into this camera and you can
sit and look at me on your phone or on
your TV or on your laptop that was the
result of somebody's vision you know
everything you've got the clothes you
wear the house you live in this
microphone that's in front of me it was
all the result of somebody's vision it's
not an accident you and I have a
marvelous imagination and everything
starts with a vision van Gogh is asked
how he did such beautiful work he said
first I dream my painting and then I
paint my dream
rule number 34 improve your self image
you know dr. Maxwell Maltz wrote a book
back around 1960 it was called
self-image psychology psycho-cybernetics
it's a phenomenal book he said it was
the greatest discovery of his generation
he was a cosmetic or reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have been a nose job or
removed a terrible scar and he noticed
that when he did that there was a
phenomenal change in their personality
but he noticed through the others he
would make a phenomenal physical change
and there was no change in their
personality and that led him to
postulate that we have two images we
have the one that's coming back from the
mirror but we've got an inner image and
that inner self-image is literally
controlling our life you will find
people that have a very poor self-image
or low self-esteem they won't look you
straight in the eye they're afraid to
shake hands with you
they're very shy and withdrawn they goes
through life hiding from life they don't
like themselves they don't know
themselves you know when a person
improves their self-image they change
their entire life their income change
their relationship change their health
changes and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you there's something
phenomenal about you you know when I
began to study this material 57 years
ago
I am very poor self-image I had a low
self-esteem
I took dumb jobs I never earned any
money I never had fun I had poor
relationships and as I started to study
start to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
I've got friends all over the world
today I earn millions of dollars I'm in
my 80s and I get as much energy as a
person in their 30s you see when you
start to understand really who you are
you're God's highest form of creation
there's things about you that just about
blow your mind as you start to study and
really understand them you'll walk a
little taller just stands a little
straighter and you know something you'll
enjoy a whole lot more of life
rule number 35 develop awareness I've
got to wake up you see all we're ever
going to get is awareness we've already
got everything the only thing we like is
the awareness of what we've got we're
God's highest form of creation there's
nothing on the planet that will equal us
well that's all that's all any of us are
after that's all the problems in the
world come from maintenance that has a
purpose of life overcome ignorance
develop awareness the only way to
overcome their ignorance is through
knowledge and the only way to get the
knowledge is to study most people they
finish school cause the books they've
got a dance over I've never done open
another book as long as I live you're
screwed it's all over
rule number 36 make decisions you know
Napoleon Hill and thinking Grow Rich
wrote an entire chapter on decision most
people never make decisions they have a
difficult time with it why is that I
think they have a difficult time because
their parents made decisions for them
until they were too old and they never
learned how to make them do you know the
one thing that I did with my kids I
never made a decision for them they
didn't like it they'd say come on don't
do that to me and I said no what do you
think you should do and I'd leave it at
that
decision-making is a phenomenal concept
and you're gonna find out as he points
out in here the successful people make
decisions very fast and they change them
very slow if and when they change them
at all and he said the people that have
difficulty in life make their decisions
very slow and then change them fast
enough to and you know decision-making
is a funny thing you and I think on
frequencies if we could see a bunch of
lines and we're thinking on a frequency
and we're on this frequency here and
we're saying I'm going to do that when
this changes this is never going to
change until you get up on this
frequency see the good that you're after
is on a higher frequency than you're
operating on a greater awareness and if
you're down here and you're thinking
here on this frequency and the good you
want up here you got to get your mind up
there how do you get up there make the
decision be there and that's really what
you have to do the second you make a
decision you flip your brain on to a
different frequency and you start to
attract thanks to you that you couldn't
you'd never get without making the
decision rule number 37 get out of the
box see someone woke me up that's all I
want to do with someone else what the
man said to me the first guy he said you
can have whatever you want well you know
they good thinking that you can get out
of the box that's where you've been
given an imagination to get out of the
box it's with your imagination that you
build images of what you want and if you
can build the image you can do it you
can hold it in your head you
your hand when we understand that like I
would imagine this goes out to a lot of
athletes says that well they can they
can have anything they want they gotta
pay the price and when doubt comes in
check it out
you can't afford the dope rule number 38
grow yourself if I want to do something
I find somebody that's already done it
and then I do exactly what they tell me
it's a simple rule to follow i I don't
read novels I don't watch movies I'd
watch documentaries or things like that
where I can learn I'm only interested in
studying something that can cause me to
become more of what I'm capable of being
yeah I think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with their life
and that's all I want to do I'm really
good at what I do I could walk by a
person in the hall like that I could
tell them exactly what they're like I
could read their energy like a book
everything goes on the inside shows on
the outside
see we're gifted with with faculties of
the mind that the average person knows
nothing about your VIN tuition the will
reason imagine a ssin perception memory
that's what separates us from all the
rest of forms of life we go through
school never learn anything about it but
you'll hear people say they have a bad
memory there's no such thing as a bad
memory everybody has a perfect memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it our imagination your imagination is
the most magnificent piece he'll said
it's the most marvelous miraculous
inconceivably powerful force the world's
ever known
I can use my imagination to project
myself into the future and bring the
future into the present and start living
there you work from the imagination you
don't work to it you work from it
backwards from the result
yeah rule number 39 surround yourself
with greatness
you know the people you surround
yourself with have been a phenomenal
impact on your life I think it was Karl
Menninger from the Medicare foundation
one time said environment is more
important than heredity the people were
surrounded by have a greater bearing on
our life and our success in life than
what's built into the genes at Birth
there's genetic conditioning there's
environmental conditioning
well this environmental conditioning
goes on all the way through life you
will find as you improve the quality of
your life improve your thinking you even
attract a different group of people into
your life and they are going to add to
your life see the people were surrounded
by their thinking is going right into
our mind we want to mix with people who
are really making it happen take a look
at your five people that you're with
most often and ask yourself if I have
children what I want them to grow up be
like them if the answer's no you better
start looking for some new friends if
the answer is yes you're already in the
right circle of people think about what
I'm saying the people were surrounded
with have a phenomenal impact on my life
and help make us who we are
rule number forty believes William James
from Harvard said believe and your
belief will create the fact all things
are possible if you believe well you
know I studied for a long time I started
to study this book Think and Grow Rich
and he talks about leaf in here he says
you're not ready for what you want until
you believe you can get it I found that
the only two sources of reference we
could go to to find out anything about
herself is science and religion they all
say you've got to believe so I get
figuring out how do you how do you
believe how do you change a belief
interesting subject because I'm going to
tell you something your results are
nothing but the manifestation of your
belief system
well our belief system now listening
carefully is based upon our evaluation
of something
and frequently when we reevaluate a
situation our belief about that
situation will change can you repeat
that our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something frequently if we
reevaluate a situation our belief about
it will change
I began reevaluating who I was I started
to study I never stopped studying and I
found as I really a 'td I had a much
higher opinion of myself I found out
things about me that I would have never
believed if you had told me the power
that's locked up within us the marvelous
system we've got do you know the blood
circulates through your veins every 33
seconds through hundreds of miles of
passageway dying just like that colors
all the food in and all the garbage out
stephane I think of the central nervous
system it's the most complex electrical
system in the world and you've got it
think of your brain an electronic
switching station like that you can
change the vibration of yourself and
everything around you we have awesome
powers and it's all based on what you
believe about you rule number 41 trade
your life for worthy goals you know the
law of success is a pretty interesting
concept there's been books written on it
stories told on it lives have been spent
looking for it let's understand that
everything operates by law the whole
universe operates by law the best
definition of success I have ever heard
was one that Earl Nightingale originated
way back 1959 he said success is the
progressive realisation of a worthy
ideal let's break that down for a moment
success is the progressive continually
moving progressive realization constant
awareness of a worthy ideal an ideal is
an idea that you have fallen in love
with and ideal is an idea that you're
intellectually emotionally and
physically involved with an ideal is an
idea that you fall in love with success
is the progressive realisation of a
worthy ideal so you don't ask are you
worthy of the
dia are you worthy of the good is it
worthy of you now now you're getting in
to love success is it worthy of you to
see what you're gonna do is trade your
life you're trading your life for
whatever it is you're going after so you
want to make up your mind whatever your
goal happens to be whatever you are
pursuing make certain it's worthy of you
because you're chained trading your life
for it the law of success calls for you
to continually moving toward a
predetermined objective in life and
bringing your life in harmony with the
laws that govern the entire universe
rule number 42 manage your activities
think of this for a moment do you know
that every living soul gets exactly the
same amount of time exactly the same
amount of time figure it out
you get all there is a hobo sleeping
under a bridge or on a park bench there
is no material possessions
none does nothing of any constructive
nature that person gets exactly the same
amount of time as the most productive
industrialist in the world we all get
exactly the same amount of time so it's
what we do at the time that makes a
difference I want you to think of the
number of time management programs
almost everyone under the Sun has time
management programs in fact I made one
one time spent a lot of money on it and
then I found out it was a dumb waste of
time and money do you know why time
can't be managed I was having breakfast
with Earl Nightingale one morning and it
was downtown Chicago and I was going
with him on his speaking engagement and
it was early in the morning he said you
want to meet for breakfast
whenever all night you said you want to
meet me I was there and I always had
some well-prepared questions and I
remember as to my syndrome how did you
learn how to master time management yeah
we're having breakfast I can still hear
his fork hit the plate he's what the
hell are you talking about
he's I've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
he's I merely manage activity and he
took a little card out of his pocket and
he said every night before I go to bed I
write down six most important things I
have to do tomorrow these are goal
achieving activities and when I wake up
that's when I start working on and if I
don't get them all done I'll add them to
tomorrow's list you should have about
six now if I have three that I didn't
get done today that doesn't mean I have
nine for tomorrow like six plus these
three those three become part of the six
you have to do the next day when you
wake up you give all your conscious
attention to do those things so you
cannot manage time but you can manage
activity you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference make certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
route number forty-three study yourself
I met a man here in Toronto he was one
that originally got me involved in study
in this race to an furred and he told me
if I didn't like the results I was
getting in my life that I was going to
have to change me because there were my
results and he said if you're gonna
change you you're gonna have to find out
something about yourself and that seemed
to make sense I don't think it was an
earth-shattering idea it wouldn't give
anybody a brain hernia but it may help
us sense to me so I started to study
myself I found most people don't know
who they are they really don't what do
you mean I mean I know my name I know my
age I know where that's not you know if
you ask the average person who they are
they'll give you their name they'll say
I'm Bob Proctor but I'm not Bob and
Proctor two words my parents give them
to me they're called names but it's not
me it's my name then some people say
well this is me but this is
me neither it's my body like you never
flown down here to the to the studio and
say body won't be in today it's sick
okay you know we don't say em hander em
leg
it's my hand my leg my body my name Who
am I well that's an interesting question
and I believe if a person will start to
study that and look for the answer
they'll find it see I think we live
simultaneously on three planes of
understanding
we're spiritual creatures we have an
intellect and we live in physical bodies
okay but because we lack awareness or
understanding of who we are were totally
locked into a physical world and we let
things outside of us control us 95% of
the population are reacting to life
they're not really living at all rule
number 44 study your will when President
John Kennedy asked the father of the
space program the famous dr. Wernher von
Braun what it would take to build a
rocket that would carry a person to the
moon and bring him back safely to earth
he answered him in five words the will
to do it the will to do it pretty light
simple answer for such an enormous
question but I'm going to tell you some
the will to do it it had a lot of power
in it what do we mean by that the will
to do it well will is one of your higher
faculties your perception reason memory
imagination intuition and the will will
is a mental faculty that gives you the
ability to hold one idea on the screen
of the mind to the exclusion of all
outside distractions you know it would
be you'd be hard-pressed to figure out
how many things are trying to grab your
attention at any given time but there's
all kinds of things going on around that
are begging your conscious attention you
can block them all out and keep one idea
on the screen of the mind with your will
will is a mental faculty that gives you
the ability to hold one ID on the screen
of the mind to the exclusion of all
outside distractions it's the will that
gives you the ability to concentrate
concentration is a powerful mental tool
how do you develop your will I'll tell
you
take your pen or a little black marker
and go opposite to your favorite chair
there's a wall opposite your favorite
chair put a little dot on the wall dude
when nobody sees you doing it and nobody
will ever notice the dots there every
time you sit in that favorite chair
focus on that dot bring all of your
conscious attention to bear on the dot
now when you look at your mind will
wander that's okay don't feel bad does
it wonder bring it back to the dot every
time it wanders if you if you
concentrate on the on that dot for a
half a second you'll probably set a
family record our mind is so busy you
focus on the dot you'll find your mind
wander don't feel bad bring it back to
the dot you can get to the point where
you can concentrate for quite a while
and I'm telling you you concentrate for
a while you're developing great powers
or get a candle in a candle holder and
put it somewhere around your favorite
chair when you're alone light the candle
and stare at the flame and stare at that
flame until you mentally become one with
the flame now again your mind is gonna
wander don't feel bad about it bring it
back to the flame just bring it back to
the flame when you learn to concentrate
on one thing you can concentrate on
anything because that is how you develop
your will rule number 45 surge up
virginity's an interesting word and like
most words it's misunderstood see the
average person is looking at opportunity
is something they're going to get so
they're out looking to get something
opportunity is what you're going to give
see it's the person that's thinking of
an idea how can I do more how can I
provide more service for the people we
provide service for do you know I spend
almost all of my time thinking of how I
can help you more than I'm helping you
I'm here in my studio
we spent a million dollars building this
studio so that I can communicate more
effectively with our clients opportunity
is in giving it's not receiving it's not
getting it's giving it's sharing it's
putting something out there
rule number 46 get real success
success is a funny word nightingale had
a great definition for it he said a
person successful if they know where
they are and they know where they're
going and they're progressively moving
in that direction
he said that success was the progressive
realisation of a worthy ideal anyone
that has a goal and they're moving
towards that they're successful most
people think that you're successful if
you have a lot of money quite often you
have a lot of money if you're successful
but it isn't
I wouldn't say mother Teresa has a lot
of money ok huh but she's a pretty
successful lady rule number 47 use your
imagination attracting what you actually
want I think James Allen put it very
well in his little book as a man
thinketh he said you don't attract what
you want you attract what you are now
think about that if you want to attract
what you want you've got to see yourself
already with it you've got to understand
that you've already got it
first of all clearly understand this
nothing is created or destroyed that
means everything's already here if not
in one state certainly in another where
did the iPhone come from the iPhone came
from a series of ideas that individuals
entertained in their mind and they kept
holding the idea until the stuff came to
them that enabled them to build the
phone the stuff had already been here
nothing is created or destroyed all
science all theology dates that if
nothing's created or destroyed
everything that is already here our
problem is we've got to wait until we
see it outside before we believe we've
got it
start dealing with the non-physical
world with the invisible world with the
world that you can't see through these
little peepers that you've got here we
call eyes start to see yourself mentally
you've been given the faculties to do
that
use your imagination see yourself
already in possession of the good you
desire that will flip your mind on to a
specific frequency and you do think on
frequencies it's on that frequency that
good you desire is going to start coming
towards you and you will start moving
toward it if you want to attract what
you actually want
you've got to see yourself now already
with it and no it's only a period of
time until you moving toward it and then
moving toward you
and you become one with it rule number
48 shift your paradigm stop and think of
any large company I don't care
anyone right you can go to the leaders
of that company and you can say who are
your stars I mean the ones that are
really making it happen and they've all
got a few say what are they doing that's
so different why don't you find out what
they're doing it teaches everybody they
all well everybody couldn't do it why
are they doing it you know something the
stars don't know why they're stars and
they'll say well they're smart some of
them aren't very smart smarts got
nothing to do with it they have shifted
their paradigm they've knocked the wall
down and they built an image and they
followed the rules they just didn't know
what they were doing I didn't know what
I was doing I was there know for a
million dollars here I had no idea what
the hell I was doing I'd say I was
cleaning offices that was almost
incidental what I was doing I was
reading this every day I was listening
to the recordings every day I was
reprogramming my subconscious mind whose
number 49 control your happiness
everybody wants to be happy but not
everybody is happy you know I could take
you back to the man that gave me this
book Rey Stanford I was a very unhappy
individual I was a sad soul believe me
and I remember one day he said Proctor
you're gonna have to change would you
like to be happy well I used to think
that was something that happened to some
people but you weren't in control of it
I really never knew that I could control
my own happiness I did not know that and
I'm gonna tell you something there's a
whole lot of people do not know that
otherwise you wouldn't find so many
people who are pretty sad
he's I'm going to tell you a secret
Proctor and he said if you get it you
can benefit from this till you're a very
old man he said you are in control of
your own happiness
now I said I'm going to tell you why
you're not happy there's a power or a
thought energy flowing into your
consciousness and you know what you do
you bottle it all up inside all of your
energies focused on you you are only
thing you think about poor me I wish
that some money I wished I wish to wish
to wish but your thoughts are always
about yourself if you find someone else
to help if you can help someone and I'm
gonna tell you there's a whole lot of
people out there want help if you will
focus on helping other people you're
gonna be one happy cat no I don't think
I got it right away
but he knew probably I wasn't gonna get
it right away and so every time I some
he's who you've been helping my man and
I don't know I wasn't helping anybody I
was trying to figure out how to get some
money how to help me I want you to think
about this for a moment there's so many
people need help
chapter 14 and the science of getting
rich is a powerful concept leave
everyone with the impression of increase
if you do that you're helping people
happiness is always found and the person
who is focusing on helping other people
and rule number 50 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is get unstuck
what keeps people stuck month after
month year after year that 97%
halation or stuff you've got people
graduating with all kinds of degrees and
the results would indicate that they
know very much at all most people don't
understand what's going on inside
there's something that's stopping them
that's called a paradigm see when
paradigms are in control nothing changes
nothing and that's why most people they
have the same results year after year
people know how to do better than
they're doing the problem is they don't
know why they're not doing what they
know how to do see it's the paradigm
that produces the result and if we're
going to change the result there's only
one way to do it just one you can change
the curve at
a man's environment is a merciless year
of him as a human being and the penises
my amethyst and love improvement all he
has to do is improve on this environment
will improve reflect the changing man
all know its power is a hundred percent
evenly president all place at the same
time your spiritual DNA is perfect so
it's mine there's perfection within you
gotta learn just draw it out now got a
special bonus cap from Bob on how to
change from the inside that I think you
could enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one where do you need to believe more in
yourself number two what's the fear that
you need to overcome and number three
how can you visualize overcoming that
fear and achieving success however once
your desire has been firmly established
it is the expectant attitude that
ensures your goal or dream is not
uprooted or replaced by any opposing
idea to see when you understand how this
power works and your conscious
relationship to it you're not going to
be knocked off track by circumstance
because you are expecting the right
thing to happen like Paul HUD C said he
said I found the 1080 Kerr lot because I
was looking for the 10 acre lot
most people don't expect it they just
think because they changed vocations
they've changed towns they've changed
spouses they've changed clothes they've
changed cars that everything's going to
happen uh-uh you don't change the
kitchen by painting the outside of the
house if you want your results to change
permanently and dramatically you get a
change of inside if you want to learn
how to change the paradigm with Bob
Procter check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when you're going ahead the only
thing you can measure
you're giving up what about what's
coming you know it's coming what you
want